SPEAKER: As customers move
workloads to Google Cloud,
they need a backup
and disaster recovery
offering that provides
low RPO and RTO,
works for a broad
set of applications,
and provides ease of use.
Customers may also want the same
cloud-based backup and disaster
recovery offering to protect
some hybrid workloads, which
will remain on premises.
Today, customers often
use multiple products
for backup, disaster recovery,
ransomware resiliency,
and data replication for
their cloud-based and hybrid
workloads.
These architectures have high
complexity and potentially high
backup and recovery times.
Actifio GO solves
these challenges
using a single
pane of glass that
works across Google Cloud
and hybrid workloads.
Actifio GO is Google Cloud's
backup and disaster recovery
offering that provides
backup and recovery
of virtual machines in
Google Cloud on Compute
Engine and VMware
Engine, as well as
hybrid VMware environments,
backup and recovery
of databases and file
systems on Google
Cloud in hybrid environments
and on physical servers,
including SAP Hana,
Oracle, SQL server,
and other major
databases, the ability
to leverage Google Cloud as
a disaster recovery target
for on premises and
Google Cloud workloads.
Using intelligent data
capture and recovery methods,
Actifio GO provides low RPO and
low RTO for backup and disaster
recovery use cases.
Customers can also utilize
cost effective Cloud Storage
for long-term retention, as
well as disaster recovery,
while still achieving
RTO of minutes
by restoring on-demand in
Compute Engine or VMware
Engine.
As Google Cloud's backup and
disaster recovery offering,
Actifio GO enables
customers to one,
protect Google Cloud
and hybrid workloads
from a single pane of
glass, while providing
application consistent
incremental forever backups.
Two, reduce the risk
of application downtime
with on-demand instant recovery
for mission critical databases,
VMs, and physical servers,
including Cloud disaster
recovery.
Three, reduce their data center
footprint and storage costs
by backing up
VMware VMs directly
to Google Cloud Storage.
Four, get started quickly with
a simple consumption-based
pricing model that's integrated
with Google Cloud billing.
So if all these great
features and benefits
sound interesting
to you, head over
to the Actifio GO page in
the Google Cloud marketplace.
Thanks for watching.